Mendelevium, which is named after one of the
most important people as
far as the periodic table is concerned, which
is Dimitri Mendeleev.
Mendelevium is named after Mendeleev, in Russia
the periodic table is
called the Mendeleev table, and you can see
here on my tie I’ve got a
picture of Mendeleev.
It’s another element which has absolutely
zero use in the real world.
He is one of the iconic, iconic, pictures
of chemists that most chemists
will recognise Mendeleev.
Ah, Mendeleev was all to do with how it was
discovered to put the
periodic table together, for a long time,
people knew that there were
different elements and that they knew that
they had different properties.
What they couldn’t do, was rationalise those
properties and understand
why certain elements behaved in a similar
manner even though in
principle they should have been very different.
But Mendeleev has another cause of fame; he
is famous in Russia
because he was the person who worked out the
standard for the
strength of vodka. So here I have a bottle
of Russian Mendeleev, you’ll
see it says Mendeleev here and vodka, with
a periodic table on it, and
here’s the formula, ethanol plus water,
and Mendeleev was the person
that worked out the standard of 40% of ethanol
in water as being vodka.
And in fact it’s remarkable the number of
experiments you read where
people have used 40% ethanol in water as the
solvent for their reaction
doubtless because they had a handy bottle
of vodka or some similar
drink.